es ist doch jedes mal wieder eine kleine
entdeckungsreise durch ein kulinarisches
eldorado tagtäglich steht uns hier die
welt offen zum beispiel in der comfort
ecke die hat in den letzten jahren
mächtig aufgemotzt hier darf gereist
werden nach china zum beispiel oder ins
indonesische rüber nach indien
bitteschön nein die heimische spätzli
pfanne lassen wir aus dann lieber ins
team zum lan oder wie klingt denn
und daheim ein kinderspiel sich von den
exotischen düften in den fernen osten
tragen lassen
wie war das nochmal es schmeckt
irgendwie um fremd
wo ist die ganze exotik hin
jetzt wollen wir es wissen von einem der
sich auskennt mit dem fremden unserer es
landschaft wir fahren mit unserem mami
zu ihm
im frankfurter bahnhofsviertel da wo man
sich auf 200 metern durch die halbe welt
essen kann treffen wir den nahrungs-
hydrologen marin trenk
hier dominieren läden und geschäfte und
restaurants aus der ganzen welt und hier
der wahre exoten in dieser ecke in
deutschen schlacht da dürften wir
vielleicht sogar noch schweinefleisch
krieg wird hier im multikulti quartier
ist für den professor die welt in
ordnung die originalität der küchen noch
intakt seit 20 jahren studiert der
globale essgewohnheiten
wird in vielen kulturen ganz ganz gerne
gegessen aber es natürlich in der
kulinarischen kranz erfahrung weil
grün arisch ist heute vieles möglich
fast alles wir essen speisen von denen
wir vor einigen jahrzehnten nur träumen
konnten vorausgesetzt wir wussten dass
es sie gibt die internationale küche ist
selbstverständlich geworden
sehr anders schmecken
bolt ist das ist ein spagat der nur sehr
schwer
da bleibt viel auf der strecke
wir haben es geahnt knüpfen dies
domestiziert der geschmack entschärft
verwässert trivialisiert
die lebens industrie bedient unser
bedürfnis nach exotischen aber sie
kreiert speisen wie es so in den
herkunftsländern nicht gibt wie alle
essen in der zwischenzeit wo immer wir
wohnen in europa
teikoku schicken und die einzige ort auf
der welt wo es nicht kriegen das
highlight und sehr gute alte diener
mittlerweile europäischer lieblings nick
was ist da dran politischem und
authentisch lammfleisch ist nördlich der
alpen selten so beliebt wie nie in
anatolien also ist man ganz schnell dazu
übergegangen ihn aus kalbfleisch ohne
rindfleisch anzubieten dann kam bse der
rinder waren und dann war man plötzlich
beim chippen döner das ist ja der
qualitätsverfall des löhner
wie schätzt der profi wohl unsere
mitgebrachten snack ein in bezug auf die
authentizität das würde ich ihn in dem
bereich etwa fantasy bringende also
fiction frei frei freier früheren spiel
mit elementen natürlich wenn man nudeln
sieht und und job sticks dabei dann ist
die assoziation mit irgendwas
asiatischen asiatischen gegeben es ist
aber schmerzen
die weltweite verbreitung und aneignen
von speisen ist eine uralte
angelegenheit
angefangen mit der verschiffung von
lebensmitteln ihrer ruf nach der
entdeckung amerikas durch kolumbus
dann der siegeszug einzelner speisen in
der kolonialzeit die eroberung englands
durch das indische curry zum beispiel
und später die verpflanzung ganze küchen
mit den ein- und auswanderer zb die
reise der neapolitanischen pizzabäcker
anten küche nach nordamerika von dort
aus in die ganze welt auch nach
norditalien unterwegs
und heute heute gibt's pizza in peking
kari in köln schien stockholm und döner
in thailand kulinarisch die brutale
globalisierte beliebigkeit
junge leute heute die essen montags
pasta mit pesto
dienstag seine mexiko pfanne mittwochs
gibt es gulasch aber mit magix angemacht
donnerstag natürlich eine pizza aus
tiefgefroren und freitags ist man
traditionell
aber auch als fertiggericht
wenn das irgendwie das alltagsverhalten
charakterisiert und ich fürchte dass das
tut dann sieht man dass junge leute bei
uns keinerlei verwurzelung in
gewachsenen esskulturen habe der
völkerkundler ist alarmiert in zeiten
multinationaler verwirrtheit müssen wir
wieder zum kochen finden man braucht
eine anbindung eine kulinarische
tradition nur dann weiß man was
irgendwie schmeckt und wie die wie die
welt kulinarisch aussieht von dort aus
kann man dann andere sachen kennenlernen
aber wenn die verloren gegangen jetzt
werde ich nur mit
zufällig zusammengewürfelten bunten
programm an fertig speisen groß geworden
bin dann fehlt mir das und dann fehlt
mir also der wesentliche element
kulinarische bildung
ok
vielleicht überlegen wir uns das noch
mal mit dem armee und dem kochen aus der
region oder aber wir verreisen
nachteilen und essen einen
unverfälschten skorpion snack aber das
ist wieder eine andere geschichte